ryad a personne ici qui me font des
gestes obscènes
des personnes ici cible d'un jet li font
des gestes horribles envers ma personne
castaldi est ce que c'est toi jamais
beinheim fait des gestes de tendresse
j'ai en michel mr non et je dis que
c'est bien plus grave que ce qui vient
d'arriver ces gens me je pense pas qu
eric n'ont même pas que c'est possible
qu'il jamais isa moi ça a pu arriver
mais ça se passe maxime jamais car avec
les doigts uniquement
merci moi je peux pas penser que tu
penses à et oui puisque la coupable a
cédé signé elle-même à la coupable c'est
vous envers vous une fois de plus envers
vous envers moi mal non regardez là bas
on sait aller boire un coup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
l'audience
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les graves dans le dos je voyais à toi
mal de gens qui disent que c'est
horrible
vous avez vous voulez vous occuper c'est
l'amour vache
bon d'accord vous partout donc c'est pas
grave mais moi je vous présente mes
excuses
isabelle je ne le prends pas mal je
prends ça comme une preuve d'amour car
j'imagine votre doigt quelque part aux
rockies à belle île en mer isabelle je
vous les russes merci